a source close to Aretha Franklin Aretha
Franklin's family tells CBS News this
morning the legendary singer is very ill
Franklin who is 76 has battled health
problems for several years now vladimir
duthiers our streaming network cbsn is
in detroit where the queen of seoul's
hometown is now rallying around her Vlad
good morning this is very sad news today
it is very sad good morning Gail this is
the church where a star was born around
six decades ago Aretha Franklin's father
was a pastor here in fact this street
right in front of me is named for him
she grew up singing for the conversation
and she continued to be involved in the
church even after she became a household
name and now New Bethel Baptist Church
is coming together for their beloved
Aretha Aretha Franklin discovered her
legendary voice here at the New Bethel
Baptist Church in Detroit where her
father was a minister Reed is not only
my daughter Aretha is just a stone sing
[Music]
even as our music style change her
gospel roots stayed with her phenomenal
reads of the church wouldn't still be
yeah pastor Robert Smith jr. says the
New Bethel Baptist Church is praying for
Franklin after learning she is seriously
ill a source close to the family told
CBS News Monday that Franklin is at home
in hospice care she had been battling
health issues in recent years
celebrities and politicians reacted to
the news of Aretha 's poor health Monday
praying for the Queen of Soul singer
Mariah Carey tweeted Hilary and I are
thinking about Aretha Franklin tonight
President Bill Clinton wrote at a
concert in Detroit Monday night Beyonce
and jay-z dedicated their show to
Franklin DJ Khaled opening for them paid
tribute to Franklin by getting the crowd
to sing respect even as Franklin's star
rose she never forgot where she came
from just weeks ago pastor Smith says
she contacted him about performing at
the Church's annual benefit concert
asking God to continue this miracle
because is great that she's made it this
long
in 2017 detroit honored franklin by
naming a street after her many of those
attending the Beyonce concert last night
had to actually cross that Street to get
there here at New Bethel parishioners
will hold an early morning vigil service
for Franklin tomorrow beyond o the
country in the world really pulling for
the Queen of Soul right what an impact
she's had for errors all over the world
all over the countries and I know that
prayer works so let's hope that this
turns out in a very good way you know
she's a fighter yes she is sure
definitely is